My whole life
was based on a lie.
Can't go back to the way things were.
A real man doesn't avoid hard things.
He faces what scares him.
Will!
Will.
-Will.
-Will!
Will!
Get dressed and buckle up, fool!
We need to talk.
The house just isn't the same when...
...Will's not home.
What's going on, Will?
I just want to take care of myself.
I've been staying in South LA.
Where'd this money come from?
Just a couple streetball games, no big deal.
Okay, now I'm worried.
I did what I did for Will's sake.
West Philly Will is back, baby!
But he's reverting back to his old ways.
Let's go.
There's this big time scout
and he's helped a lot of dudes get to the pros.
That fancy Bel-Air team
got you and your game soft.
If you come work with me, sky's the limit!
We need to talk about our partnership.
You're a boss,
I'm just trying to bring it out.
If you don't set the tone,
she's gonna keep on walking all over you.
I was trying to be someone different.
The BSU, the protest,
all people see are my mistakes.
Never ever let anyone try to change you.
Can't believe you're going back so soon.
Well, Babe, you know
I can't sit still for too long.
When is it my time to feel valued?
I wish to create a legacy
where we are represented.
I think it's time you take
the gloves off, Baby.
Right, Carlton?
Carlton!
You need to watch your mouth!
Maybe I am on the wrong team.
We can't be friends anymore.
He can't do this to you!
Fight for your principles!
I have anxiety trying to fit into
this goddamn Bel-Air bubble!
We all need to step up!
You got any Geoffrey wisdom?
(chuckles)
Nothing that you wanna hear.